[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القبله هي وجهه المصلي وقبله المسلمين
الكعبه وفي اول الاسلام كانت القبله بيت
المقدس ولهذا تسمى باولى القبلتين وفي 17
رجب من السنه الثانيه للهجره تحولت القبله
من بيت المقدس الى مكه والامه الاسلاميه
الامه الوحيده التي تستخدم مواقع النجوم
والشمس لتحديد القبله فالشمس اساسا في
تحديد القبله وظلها اساسا في تحديدا
مواقيت الصلاه الظل المباشر صلاه الظهر
وصلاه العصر والظل الغير مباشر صلاتين
العشاء والفجر اللي هو الشفق والمغرب مع
مغيب الشمس الى اي شطر من حياتي ويممه وكل
الذي فيها سموم وحلقمه وما ابتغي منها
وقدما عرفتها وقد عشت فيها نامت
اتبرموا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ووقت صلاه الظهر يحين اذا زالت الشمس ووقت
العصر اذا صار ظل كل شيء مثله وخلال هذه
الايام سيكون الوقت الابكر لصلاه العصر
على جل البلدان العربيه والعصر سمي بهذا
لمعاصرتها وقت المغرب وهي صلاه الوسطى
حافظوا على الصلاه الوسطى وقوموا لله
قانتين
[موسيقى]